okay so we're winding down our CPAC
coverage we'll talk a little bit more
about it at the end of the show but uh
the the sort of important thing that
comes out of CPAC the conservative
political action conference every year
we get closer to an election it becomes
more relevant is the CPAC straw poll
where attendees vote as to who they uh
would like to see or approve of in terms
of the next Presidential nominee and as
it turns out Donald Trump is still very
much in control
um of the Republican Party CNN report
Trump wins CPAC straw poll as attendees
clamor for him to run again former
president Donald Trump bathed in the
adulation of an adoring crowd at CPAC
Sunday as he easily won the informal
straw poll of attendees when they were
asked who they'd like to see Run for the
White House in 2024 let's go to a video
of CPAC announcing the results when
Trump is included and the results when
Trump is not included take a look at
this first one where
Canario where he says
he says Ron DeSantis 68 percent
secretary Pompeo at five
and Donald Trump Jr four and now let's
take a look at what it looks like when
Donald Trump is in the race for 2024.
are we ready
70 percent
21 percent
[Applause]
go ahead all right and finally we asked
an approval question of Donald Trump
across the conference there was very
very little disagreement
with a 98 approval rating
for Donald Trump Okay so
really no big surprise there we were of
the impression that Trump was still
completely in control of the Republican
party and he clearly seems to be when
you include him he easily wins the straw
poll how much of that is people who are
just excited by his celebrity and Trump
being there yeah maybe to some degree
there are some of them the other steady
component
is that Ron DeSantis seems to be very
clearly out ahead of the rest of the
pack as a possible second place
Contender someone who I mean listen if
he tried to fight Trump for the
nomination I don't know what would
happen because much of the Santa's
support comes from the fact that he is
seen as Trump adjacent and that Donald
Trump has generally been very supportive
of Rhonda Santos if Donald Trump didn't
run and particularly if Trump didn't run
and said support Ron DeSantis the
numbers right now to me suggest Ronda
santis would be a pretty clear favorite
um if it's not Trump for the 2024
Republican nomination now as I've said
before I think this is extraordinarily
dangerous why is it dangerous as I've
said before if you say
assume that the president will be a
republican who would you like it to be
and in those cases I've typically said
well if it has to be a republican I
would lean towards somebody like Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney is no great guy I
don't agree with him about a bunch of
stuff but he's at least sort of like on
this planet and I know people will say
David oh what are you talking about
Romney's horrible yeah Romney's horrible
but if the question is Romney or Trump
I'm going with Romney or in the past I
would say well somebody like John McCain
as an example
um you know previously some people won't
like this but like William F Buckley
okay will you a bunch of William F
Buckley's foreign policy is is horrible
but William F Buckley versus Trump what
one of them is a thinker at least okay
and we won't agree on a lot of stuff but
that that would be if you said it's got
to be a republican that's the line I'm
thinking of DeSantis is very much in the
trumpian wing completely cartoonish
opened everything like months into the
pandemic and Florida has just been a
complete and total mass now Florida's
seeing again some of the highest rates
they just don't do anything I was just
there it was crazy anti-vaxxer told me
their mom became magnetized from getting
the vaccine DeSantis is completely
Bonkers but
he's more competent than Trump
significantly more competent than Trump
and so when we look at you know I
already said if it's Trump Biden I think
Biden's in trouble if it's Trump Harris
I think Kamal is in trouble uh the other
side of this is well if it's DeSantis
instead of trump if DeSantis can spend
the next couple of years building name
recognition
he is far more competent in that Evil
Genius sort of way than is Donald Trump
and I would be very concerned about uh
about about Ron DeSantis but for now
Trump remains in control of the
Republican Party clearly the favorite
and we're going to continue following
how those numbers change as we get into
in particular you know when we get into
the midterms and that's starting soon
we're four months from the start of the
midterms basically
um if Trump's picks don't do well in
2022 that could really weaken Trump and
we're going to wait and see what happens
on that